they might be old and white but Hillary
Clinton and Bernie Sanders just want to
be one thing down why they want the
black vote
Thanks producer Brooke yes the black
phone that mythical orb that contains
the desires of every black American that
once in a candidate's clutches will
render them politically invincible
forever I mean it's pretty important no
other voting bloc has gotten candidates
to carry around an urban dictionary over
the Constitution am i staying woke I
don't even know what this means
I am already awake or get a candidate to
whip and nae nae stop yes it's a mad
dash to show voters who's more committed
to racial justice which thanks to the
black lives matter movement calling out
police brutality and the unfair criminal
justice systems that have destroyed
black communities is now one of the
biggest issues of this Democratic
primary meanwhile the Republicans have
barely said a thing guess it's just not
a platform point on planet douche thank
you for the book and whose home the
black political and entertainment worlds
are picking their sides I truly believe
that senator Bernie Sanders is the right
man to lead this country if you want to
make sure Republicans don't take us
backward help Hillary move us forward
but who's got the better record as a New
York senator Hillary has represented
more african-americans than there are
people in Vermont
Bernie's home state in the 60s Hillary
organized a two-day strike on Wellesley
campus to recruit more black students
and professors and Bernie Sanders was
arrested protesting segregationist
policies in Chicago and in the 80s he
supported another Outsiders historic run
for the presidency Jesse Jackson Jackson
who is still undecided on who he will
back ooh
build that burn but then we have Hales
husband as president bill enacted some
of the harshest reforms the criminal
justice system strict sentencing three
strikes laws basically expanding the
prison industrial complex and while
Hillary is not
husband even though being a former first
lady has totally been the springboard of
her political career she did back him on
a 1994 crime bill saying that some black
youth are super predators no conscience
no empathy we can talk about why they
ended up that way but first we have to
bring them to heel since then both
Clintons have walked back on their
support of tough on crime bills it turns
out that Bernie Sanders actually voted
for the bill though he had reservations
but he did vote against another Clinton
legacy that was disastrous for poor
people and people of color welfare
reform in many respects our country is
becoming a poorer and poorer nation and
not to talk about the causes of poverty
is absolutely absurd
he was right to hate the legislation it
cut fifty four billion dollars in
funding from welfare and limited the
time people could be on it a recent
study found that between 1996 and 2011
the number of families living on $2 a
day more than doubled
fast-forward to today both Bernie and
Hillary have had speeches interrupted by
black lives matter protesters and both
have set up meetings with organizers
they've also both outlined bold plans to
end mass incarceration and police
misconduct in the end race is a bigger
issue in this election than it was when
a black man was frontrunner thanks Obama
so who is going to win over the black
vote and more importantly who's gonna
stay woke